TOMORROW THEY'RE GOING TO HEAR
FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Bret: PETER DOOCY AT CPAC.
THANKS.
THERE ARE NEW CHARGES TONIGHT
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT'S FORMER
CAMPAIGN CHAIRMAN AND A
LONG-TIME BUSINESS ASSOCIATE.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE HAS THE NEWS.
SERIOUS TROUBLE FOR PAUL
MANAFORT.
>> FORMER TRUMP AIDS CHARGED
WITH MORE FINANCIAL CRIMES AND
TO FEDERAL JURISDICTION.
WASHINGTON, D.C., AND NOW A
SEPARATE 32 COUNT INDICTMENT IN
VIRGINIA OVER BANK AND TAX
FRAUD.
ALLEGEDLY LAUNDERING MORE THAN
$30 MILLION.
SOURCES CALLING IT IT CLASSIC
LEGAL PYLON AND MEMOS OVER
SURVEILLANCE ABUSE ENTER A NEW
PHASE.
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
RANKING DEMOCRAT ADAM SCHIFF
SAYS HE WANTS THE COUNTER MEMO
OUT THIS WEEK.
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE FBI OVER
WHAT WILL BE BLACKED OUT OR
REDACTED ARE NEARLY COMPLETE.
WHITE HOUSE SPOKESMAN SAID THERE
WOULD NO BE -- BEING A UP.
>> ONCE IT MEETS THE FBI'S
STANDARDS, WE WOULD SUPPORT ITS
RELEASE.
>> JUST LIKE THE REPUBLICAN
STAFF ♪
♪ RELEASED EARLIER THIS MONTH,
SOURCE CLOSE TO THE PROCESS HAD
THE DEMOCRATS VERSION WILL
LIKELY REQUIRE THE PRESIDENT TO
DECLASSIFY.
REPUBLICAN MEMO DRAFTED BY DEVIN
NUNES ALLEGES SURVEILLANCE'S
REVIEWS BY THE FBI AND JUSTICE
DEPARTMENTS KNEW THAT THE TRUMP
DOSSIER WAS FOUNDED BY THE DNC.
WITHHELD SPECIFICS FROM A
NATIONAL SECURITY OF COURT WHEN
IT APPLIED FOR SURVEILLANCE
WARRANTS FOR CARTER PAGE.
REPUBLICANS SAY THE COUNTER MEMO
IS UNLIKELY TO DIRECTLY
CHALLENGE THE FINDINGS.
COMMITTEE DEMOCRATS SAY THE
REPUBLICAN ACCOUNT IS DEEPLY
FLAWED.
>> THE FBI AND DOJ ARE COMPRISE
A VERY GOOD PEOPLE, NOT ACTING
POLITICALLY.
DOING THEIR WORK ON THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE'S BEHALF.
I WANT TO SEE THE DEMOCRATIC
REPUTATION.
THE MEMO WILL SHOW THAT A LOT OF
THE ALLEGATIONS WERE MADE AND
THEN NUNES MEMO WERE NOT
CORRECT.
>> FOX NEWS CONFIRMS DAVID JAY
KRAMER HAS INVOKED HIS FIFTH
AMENDMENT RIGHT NOT TO TESTIFY.
KRAMER WAS BRIEFED ON THE
DOSSIER BY CHRISTOPHER STEELE
WAS A CRITICAL LINK IN THE
DOSSIER'S TO THE FBI.
FOX NEWS ASKED WHY KRAMER TOOK
THE FIFTH AND IF HE HELPED GET
THE DOSSIER TO BUZZFEED.